estas imágenes muestran a residentes
serbios rompiendo un cordón de seguridad
luego intentaron tomar el ayuntamiento
antes de ser dispersados
escenas como estas se produjeron el
lunes en tres zonas del norte de kosovo
una región predominantemente Serbia los
enfrentamientos causaron heridas a
decenas de soldados de la otan la
organización condenó los ataques al
contrarrestar los sectores más activos
de la multitud varios soldados de los
contingentes italiano y húngaro fueron
objeto de ataques no provocados y
sufrieron heridas traumáticas con
fracturas y quemaduras debido a la
explosión de artefactos incendiarios
desde el viernes manifestantes piden la
destitución de los alcaldes de origen
albanés que acaban de tomar posesión de
sus cargos solo tenemos dos peticiones
que nos dejen entrar en el ayuntamiento
y que se vayan de aquí mientras ustedes
estén aquí nosotros Seguiremos aquí
también pueden hacer que nos vayamos por
la fuerza pero volveremos otra los
funcionarios fueron designados en
elecciones organizadas por las
autoridades kosovares pero los comicios
Fueron boicoteados por los residentes en
su mayoría serbios solo 1500 de los
45.000 electores inscritos votaron el
lunes el presidente de Serbia Alexander
culpó al Primer Ministro kosovar Alvin
los serbios de kosovo y sé cómo se
sienten en lo difícil que es para ellos
a que no entren en conflicto con la otan
No porque yo tenga miedo porque alguno
de nosotros tenga miedo ninguno de
nosotros tiene nada que perder sino
porque eso es lo que curti más quiere
según al menos 50 serbios resultaron
heridos en los enfrentamientos tras el
comienzo de la violencia Belgrado puso
al ejército en alerta máxima